[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion
lassen sie uns über hoffnung sprechen
die hoffnung ist auch ein ansteckendes
virus diesen plakat zur folge ist
hoffnung hochansteckend und vielleicht
gibt es tatsächlich keine
schutzmaßnahmen die ihre ausbreitung
verhindert doch worauf genau soll man
denn eigentlich hoffen wie gelangt man
zu einer hoffnungsvollen grundhaltung
und ist religiöser glaube dabei
voraussetzung
antworten auf diese fragen erhoffe ich
mir von meinem heutigen gast es ist der
theologe und philosoph aus berlin
hartmut von saft ganz herzlich
willkommen sind sie da er von sassan
enthalten ist zu vernehmen dass sich
eine gewisse hoffnungslosigkeit breit
macht eine resignation es ist von
pessimismus die rede
seit über einem jahr leben wie jetzt in
so etwas wie einem ausnahmezustand
erlegen massive einschränkungen was
haben sie für erfahrungen und
beobachtungen gemacht in den letzten
zwölf monaten bei denen sie an ihr
forschungsthema hoffnung anknüpfen
können man wird vielleicht zwei ebenen
unterscheiden können das eine ist die
ebene der einzelnen erfahrungen und
erlebnisse da haben wir erfahrungen von
verlust des lebens der existenzgrundlage
der gesundheit über leute die praktisch
gar nicht von der krise betroffen sind
und andere die von ihr profitieren
und dann gibt es eine andere ebene die
für meinen forschungsfeld durchaus sagen
vielleicht sogar noch interessanter ist
mich die erfahrung mit der erfahrung
also die ebene in der wir versuchen
durch generation eine rahmung zu
schaffen in die diese einzelnen
erfahrung integriert werden
ein beispiel es gibt in den letzten
tagen muss man sagen sehr viele artikel
darüber
sowohl die usa als auch in deutschland
derzeit etwa artikel die uns daran
erinnern dass wir nicht hoffen
und durch den modus der kritik die
abwesenheit der hoffnung sozusagen
kritisieren und uns dazu auffordern oder
ein laden der hoffnungsvolle mit der
situation umzugehen jetzt wo licht am
ende des tunnels ist
die zeichnen sie sich selbst als ein
hoffnungsvolle menschen ja ich würde
sagen dass ich ein hoffnungsvoller
mensch bin
woran machen sie das fest den
pessimisten und den optimisten scheidet
er von dem hoffnungsvollen menschen dass
die hoffnung auf die möglichkeiten geht
die vor einem liegen und ich würde sagen
dass ich mich auf die konzentriere und
nicht irgendwelche
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung mache die
die anderen beiden er bevorzugen würde
schauen wir uns mal ein bisschen genau
an worüber wir eigentlich sprechen wenn
wir von hoffnung sprechen weil es gibt
viele begriffe die nahe an diesen
begriff dran sind der hoffnung heraus
nämlich dasselbe bedeuten
hier unterscheidet sich beispielsweise
hoffnung von optimismus
ja die semantische nachbarschaft in dem
bereich ist eng bevölkert könnte man
sagen wir haben also zahlreiche begriffe
die hoffnung optimismus hatten sie
gesagt es gibt so etwas wie antizipation
vorfreude also ausrichtung auf
zukünftige güter und dann gibt es eine
reichhaltige corona von gegen begriffen
das ist eben der pessimismus angst
furcht manchmal wird auch zionismus und
resignation dazu gezählt
und die sollte man möglichst
unterscheiden dabei gibt es natürlich
sofort das problem dass wir in der
alltagssprache diese klaren
unterscheidung so nicht unbedingt haben
wir haben da überlappungen und die
philosophie wenn sie begriffs analyse
betreibt man sich um diese begriffe
bemüht geht er auf die unterscheidungen
an denen sich dann etwas zeigt zu ihrer
frage jetzt was der unterschied
unterschied ist zwischen hoffnung und
optimismus kann man vielleicht sagen das
kann man sich zu einem beispiel deutlich
machen stellen sie sich vor jemand
kriegt eine verheerende krebs einer
diagnose ihr freund den sie begleiten
und das wird nun alles dafür getan dass
es wieder gut geht und nach
chemotherapie und all diesen dingen wie
man dann da macht kommt der arzt und
sagt das hat nicht angeschlagen und
sieht nicht gut aus kann man in dieser
situation ob die
bis sein nein im anbetracht der fakten
müssen sie wenn sie optimistisch vorher
waren oder zuversichtlich dass wir auch
noch mal ein anderer begriff ihren
optimismus aufgeben wenn sie nicht
einfach weitere gründe haben die diese
art von anderen gründen sagen toppen
es wäre rational dann nicht optimistisch
zu sein und vielleicht sogar
pessimistisch zu sein sind sie in der
situation gezwungen die hoffnung
aufzugeben nein was uns zeigt ist das
pessimismus und hoffnung vereinbar sind
und dass man vielleicht sogar sagen
könnte der pessimismus hat eine gewisse
affinität sogar zum hoffen weil ihnen
das noch bleibt während eine
individuelle wirklichkeitsnahe analyse
genau dieses beispiels ja es sieht nicht
gut aus die diagnose ist
niederschmetternd dazu zwingt realist
und gegebenenfalls sogar pessimist zu
sein ist das was terry eagleton in
seinem buch hoffnungsvoll aber nicht
optimistisch mein nein eagleton meint
etwas anderes das buch lebt sehr stark
davon wieder der titel ja auch sagt
davon dass beide elemente stark
entgegengesetzt werden aber mit einmal
an grund und der grund ist dass der
hoffnung wie häufig vorgeworfen wird
dass sie blind ist dass sie eben nicht
ein blick für die realitäten hat dass
sie uns entfernt von der gegenwart und
den dingen wie sie nur einmal sind was
auch mal das dann heißen mag
und der optimismus wird jetzt genau mit
diesen schwierigkeiten belegt das heißt
also all das was so schwierig erscheint
und gegen diese art mit der hoffnung
oder mit der zukunft umzugehen dass wir
den optimistischen part zuge
schanz und die hoffnung steht dann
sozusagen umso glanzvoller da und steht
dann für die positiven elemente die wir
in so einer zukunftsorientierung haben
gehen wir einen weiteren begriff über
dahinter auch in der nähe der hoffnung
angesiedelt ist nämlich vertrauen
wie würden sie denn das verhältnis
charakterisieren zwischen hoffnung und
vertrauen
ja man könnte also einerseits sagen dass
wir hofft mit blick auf die zukunft
wieder auf die gehofft wird man auch ein
bestimmtes vertrauen hat das kann jetzt
unterschiedliches heißen es hat kann zum
beispiel heißen dass die externen gründe
oder umstände die die realisierung des
hoffnungs gutes beeinflussen wir haben
sind zahlreiche dass man darauf gehofft
dass die eintreten werden wir haben es
ja bei der hoffnung mit etwas zu tun das
schon immer witzig führt dass die dinge
ungewiss sind dass sie sich nicht
vollständig unseren taten verdanken
sondern dass wir darauf angewiesen sind
und auf merken müssen sozusagen das das
externe faktoren gibt die auch hinzu
kommen müssen dass das hoffnungs gut was
auch immer es ist dann eintritt
darauf kann man vertrauen mit dem
vertrauen ist allerdings auch unter
werden dann wieder die unterschiede
zwischen hoffen und vertrauen deutlich
mehr ganz anderer dimension angesprochen
vertrauen machte er deutlich dass ein
personal missverständnis auch gehen kann
einer beziehung also ich vertraue auf
jemand ich vertraue dir und diese
dimension kommt sich das vertrauen noch
hinzu
da wird es sozusagen geht es eher um
relation im personalen das ist mit der
hoffnung nicht unbedingt verbunden aber
man hofft ja auch auf etwas wird auf
eine person das doch sehr nah
beieinander tja es ist bei ihm nah
beieinander es gibt auch einige
philosophen und philosophen die fast so
weit gehen dass beides zu identifizieren
ja und die differenzen die ich gerade
angedeutet hatte in gewisser weise zu
kassieren oder anders zu erklären oder
vielleicht sogar weg zu erklären hier
sind sozusagen vielleicht eher tendenzen
gemeint und dann ist natürlich immer
auch die frage welche art von theorie
man bemüht um die hoffnung theoretisch
philosophisch zusammen und wie das mit
dem hoffen mit dem vertrauens begriff
aussieht und dann sieht man da
vielleicht auch differenzen dann kommt
es darauf an welche weiteren annahmen
man dann eigentlich macht zum beispiel
indem man die freistaates frage stellt
also von welchem status ist eigentlich
die hoffnung oder das vertrauen handelt
sich um eine emotion ist eine
disposition
eine fähigkeit und je nachdem wie man
hier votiert kommende andere differenzen
in den blick das kommt dann sehr darauf
an wie das theoretische setting
ich erinnere nicht dass sie einen satz
in unserem vorgespräch gesagt haben der
nicht doch sehr nachdenklich oder aber
auch beeindruckt hat sie sagten nämlich
hoffnung hat nichts mit zukunft zu tun
per se mal das habe ich eigentlich
glaube ich gar nicht so richtig
verstanden weil eben sagen sie doch
mehrfach aus es ist auf ein zukunfts gut
ausgelastet ja das eine schließt das
andere nicht aus es ist natürlich ein
bisschen zugespitzt formuliert aber ich
will nichts nicht sofort zurück rudern
sondern das vielleicht so
kontextualisiert man kann aus meiner
sicht zwei sehr unterschiedliche
hoffnungs begriffe unterscheiden und das
wird viel zu selten gemacht der eine
hoffnungs begriff ist tatsächlich einer
dem man den proportionalen hoffnungs
begriff nennt oder den materialen da
geht es also um material also content
eine bestimmte einen bestimmten inhalt
die man im blick hat hoffen dass das um
das der fall ist
hynix und da können wir jetzt triviale
oder auch existenzielle dinge einordnen
diese diese six liegt in der zukunft das
hat was mit zukunft zu tun ich hoffe
dass ich nachher den flieger bekomme
oder ich hoffe dass die klausur gut
ausgeht oder dergleichen mehr das sind
alles hoffnungs güter die in der zukunft
liegen und sofern es sagt die intuition
dass wir es mit ausstehenden
sachverhalten zu tun haben vollkommen
richtig
die story ist damit aber noch nicht
beendet und es gibt einen anderen
hoffnungs begriff der häufig
unterschlagen wird der aber finde ich in
der theologie sehr gut bedacht wird
und den könnte man den modellen
hoffnungs begriffen
also damit ist die art und weise gemeint
der modus in dem wir unsere gesamte
existenz unserer lebensvollzug
eigentlich selber vollführen von
wittgenstein dem philosophen gibt es die
schöne beobachtung das für denjenigen
der glücklich ist die welt eine
vollkommen anderer ist als für den der
unglücklich ist
sie würden in gewisser weise in zwei
welten leben
das kann sogar dieselbe person sein die
in zwei welten als eine person lebt das
können wir auf die hoffnung und den
modellen begriff der hoffnung an wänden
und sagen
derjenige der hoffnungsvoll durchs leben
geht lebt offenbar an einer anderen welt
als derjenige dem das nicht möglich ist
steht das nicht kann nicht will aus
welchen gründen auch immer
und damit haben wir jetzt einen anderen
begriff der auch grammatisch anders
funktioniert hoffen das ist offenbar ein
war eine tätigkeit formen die neben
anderen steht wissen dass meinen dass
für wahr halten dass das und das der
fall ist
während der moderne hoffnungs programm
hatte ich anders funktioniert
hoffnungsvoll durchs leben gehen ist
eine art verbale bestimmung das heißt
diese abwärme die also zum verb kommt
werbung bestimmen wir die tätigkeiten
die wir sonst so vollführen näher sind
qualifizierungen wie wir unser leben
vollführen und die frage ist natürlich
bei unterscheidungen immer zwischen dem
einblicke von dem anderen wie hängen die
jetzt zusammen und ich würde gerne dafür
argumentieren dass der moderne hoffnungs
begriff in bestimmter weise dem anderen
dem materialen vorgeordnet ist und dann
sieht man dass man einerseits die
zukunftsvisionen der hoffnung nicht
verabschieden muss das wäre absurd aber
waren sie gleichzeitig auch warum die
hoffnung nicht sofort mit zukunfts
gütern identifiziert werden müsste denn
bei einem modalen hoffnungs begriff ist
es sehr deutlich dass alle drei zeitnah
also zukunft vergangenheit aber vor
allen dingen auch die gegenwart bestimmt
sind und mit diesem hoffnungs begriff
qualifiziert werden und deshalb sind
sozusagen nicht nur die zukünfte im
blick sondern unsere ganze gegenwart
wenn sie über hoffnung forschen und
nachdenken dann tun sie das sowohl als
theologe wie auch als philosoph
bringen sie diese beiden denkweisen
dabei zusammen oder ist das je eine
unterschiedliche denkweise oder denken
sie von verschiedenen standpunkten aus
ja es gibt ja viele begriffe oder man
könnte auch sagen sprachspiele die in
beiden bereichen also sowohl dem sagen
wir mal säkularen mit dem
nichtreligiösen und auch dem religiösen
zu hause sind dazu gehört dank liebe
auch vertrauen und eben auch die
hoffnung das ist ganz deutlich dass
beide in den beiden bereichen
wir könnten sagen beiden weisen das
leben zu führen beheimatet sind und
deshalb bietet es sich an von beiden
seiten auch zu kommen und dann zu sehen
wie sich das auf den beiden seiten also
glauben und unglauben wenn man das jetzt
auf diesen binärcode vereinfacht bringen
möchte verhalten und nun ist es so und
das scheint mir ja sozusagen eine
theologische grundentscheidung zu sein
geht man eher davon aus dass sozusagen
kontinuität zwischen den beiden
bereichen dann geht man eher auf denen
die gemeinsamkeiten und würde vielleicht
eher zu der these tendieren es gibt
eigentlich gar kein unterschied zwischen
dem glauben und hoffen und dem hoffen
ohne irgendeine religiöse
grundorientierung oder man hält es eher
mit den differenzen und möchte an diesen
differenzen etwas zeigen und ich würde
sagen ich tendiere eher zu dieser
zweiten haltung nämlich nicht sofort
davon auszugehen dass hoffen eben sagen
wir mal nicht religiösen und im kontext
des glaubens identisch funktionieren und
dann erklären sie das doch bitte gleich
alles also werde ich sie richtig
verstehe ist ein religiöses hoffen und
ein nicht religiöses um ein säkulares
hoffen für sie qualitativ nicht dasselbe
mit qualitativ meine ich auch nicht
normativ ja es ist weder mit schlecht
oder gut verbunden mit irgendwelchen
wertungen es ist so nicht funktioniert
einfach anja es geht um strukturelle
fragen man könnte auch sagen um
grammatische fragen wie funktioniert
dieser begriff im einen oder anderen
bereich
und wenn man sich die wird differenzen
anschaut über die man sehr viel lernen
kann bei diesen phänomenen deshalb würde
ich immer sagen man muss in beiden
bereichen gebildet sein
damit man nicht unbedingt ausgebildet
seien über gebildet sein um diesem
phänomen haar zu werden oder frau dann
zeigt sich einiges strukturelles und
sehr interessante ist wenn man diese
differenzen im blick nimmt
ich will mal ein beispiel nennen ich
würde sagen wer glaubt in einem
religiösen sinn hofft auch
notwendigerweise umgekehrt formuliert es
wäre total seltsam wenn wir sagen würden
ich glaube an gott und ich lebe mein
leben in einer bestimmten weise ich
betrachte meinen kollegen als nächsten
und die welt nicht als
kausalzusammenhang sondern als gottes
gute schöpfung und mich selbst als
sünder und gerechtfertigten der frau
dort steht ja das sind zwei ganz
traditionell formeln wie die
selbstbeschreibung dann laufen würde die
schon theologisch durchtränkt ist aber
ich verstehe mich nicht als hoffen die
menschen dass wir total seltsam ist in
der frage der christlichen tradition
ganz stark eingebunden und eingebettet
ist diese dinge zusammen gehören ich
würde sagen notwendigerweise
zusammengehören und jetzt sehen wir auch
den unterschied zu der säkularen
hoffnung
die ist natürlich mit glauben nicht
verbunden dass das folgt aus der
definition
aber wenn wir jetzt glauben in einem
nichtreligiösen sind verhandeln da haben
wir auch glauben es auch sagen und wenn
wir die existenz und da und gucken auch
wiederum oder als einen lebensvollzug
dann ist es sehr gut vorstellbar dass
die leute nicht hoffen oder dass sie
nicht hoffen können und dass diese
möglichkeit besteht und das würde ich
sagen ist einer der vielen unterschiede
die wir zum glauben ziehen können denn
da würde ich sagen dass das ein
missverständnis wenn man sagen würde
ich glaube aber ich hoffe nicht also das
heißt wenn ich sie richtig verstehe es
ist schon eine gewisse voraussetzung für
einen glauben nein für eine hoffnung zu
haben das ist eine eben eine form an
glauben an eine höhere macht gibt also
höhere macht kann jetzt sehr
unterschiedliches heißen für das
säkulare hoffen gibt es offenbar
diese voraussetzung nicht das hat müsste
man vorsichtig sein dass man sagt eine
voraussetzung des hoffens wäre so eine
sagen wir mal metaphysische annahme dass
das ist offenbar nicht der fall
und selbst im kontext des glaubens und
der glaubenden hoffnung oder des
hoffnungsvollen glaubens ist die
variante einer höheren macht erst einmal
aus zu buchstabieren und die theologie
bemüht sich darum das zutun von höheren
mächten ist nur teilweise oder nur sehr
auslegungsbedürftig die rede
ich würde auch nicht unbedingt sagen
dass sich um voraussetzungen handelt
also dass und das muss gegeben werden
und dann und dann sind diese dinge
möglich ich würde eher vorsichtiger
formulieren und sagen wenn du das machst
ist das und das mit gegeben also
beispielsweise wenn du fußball spielst
musst du dich an die abseitsfalle halten
wenn du das spiel vernünftig spielen
möchtest und so ist es mit den blauen
augen wer glaubt hofft dass es aber
keine kondition aale beziehung also eine
der voraussetzungen und dann gibt es
bestimmte folgerungen es ist eher eine
begriffliche dass wenn das und das der
fall ist dann ist das und dass ein
unternehmen wie man sagen könnte also
ein ist in dem begriff schon enthalten
und ich würde sagen dass es nicht nur
für die hoffnung geht ja es ist auch für
den dank beispielsweise auch relevant
oder für das vertrauen diese dinge sind
alle mit gesetzt für den der geglaubt
und für den der an gott glaubt
das ist eben in dem säkularen begriff
nicht unbedingt mit gegeben und da sehen
wir wieder die unterschiede zwischen
beiden seiten und der möglichkeit sich
von beiden zu nähern um etwas neues über
diesen beruf zu lernen also worin
hoffnung begründet es ist schalten jetzt
klarer sein für die religiöse seite
aber worauf eigentlich religiöse
menschen hoffen dass ist damit noch
nicht gesagt ja hier unterscheiden sich
auch die religion sehr deutlich aber für
die christliche tradition sind die
hoffnung scooter sehr sehr traditionell
und selbst noch in einem in einer
säkularisierten welt
schwingen sie mit strukturieren
vielleicht sogar auch durch
säkularisierte unser leben das sind die
hoffnung auf das ewige leben auf ist das
denn keine glaubensgewissheit weil wenn
man von hoffnung spricht das schenkt ja
immer auch noch diese möglichkeit des
nichtantretens mit sie ist das keine
glaubensgewissheit im christentum wenn
sie von hoffnung auf ewiges leben
sprechen das ist eine glaubensgewissheit
wer glauben strukturiert sein leben in
dem er oder sie das leben auf diese
hoffnung ausrichtet das ist äußerst auch
nicht auf die gewissheit die idee die
gewissheit kann man jetzt
unterschiedlich auslegen man kann sagen
dass diese dinge gewiss sind oder wie
auch wiederum wittgenstein einmal gesagt
hat das ist die unerschütterlichkeit des
glaubens und die überträgt sich auch auf
die konkreten hoffnungsgebiet
beispielsweise ja auch verstehen und
ewiges leben auch in gewisser weise
gerichts vorstellung also das herstellen
von gerechtigkeit ja heil von frieden ja
friede spielt eine große rolle was da
vorgelagert ist scheint mir in der
biblischen tradition vor allen dingen
etwas zu sein das auch wieder was man
den modus zu tun hat nämlich die idee
das 9
also es gibt wenn viele wendungen der
neue bund die neue schöpfung das neue
jerusalem
ja da sind also alles hoffnungs güter
die wiederum sehr auslegungsbedürftig
sind was dahintersteckt ist dass am ende
alles neu gemacht wird jetzt die frage
was am ende heißt ja es ist also ein
zukunfts bericht der ungefähr die logik
eines theologisch sanktionieren
wetterberichts hat ja wir sagen etwas
was dann eintreten soll oder ist es
anders gemeint ich würde sagen dass es
anders gemeint es hat keiner ist keine
zukunfts aussage über dinge die dann
aufstehen und die theologie wüsste
besser als die kosmologie was dann am
ende der tage passiert sondern es ist
eine aussage darüber wie man jetzt die
gegenwart strukturiert und sie jetzt
versteht aber was in der zukunft
vorstellung des christlichen glaubens
ganz grundsätzlich denke ich auch in der
säkularen welt prägend es ist überhaupt
die idee dass so etwas gibt wie eine
entwicklung der geschichte
ja dass wir auf etwas auch sind und dass
wir die gegenwart im lichte einer
bestimmten zukunft die im glauben sehr
traditionell beschrieben wird sehen das
heißt auch hier ist die zukunft im blick
auf die gegenwart relevant und zentral
denn wer hofft sieht die gegenwart jetzt
anders als der oder die denen es nicht
möglich ist und die andere hoffnung
später haben also es ist eine
qualifizierung dessen was jetzt passiert
und dann kriegt auch das ganze kapitel
der frage der letzten dinge wie es in
der theologie heißt ein anderes an ein
neues kolorit das könnte heißen die
letzten dinge die zusagen zeitlich die
letzten dinge sind am ende aller tage
oder waren sie hat die letzten dinge
sind die entscheidenden dinge also die
die jetzt entscheidend sind für die wir
uns jetzt entscheiden so oder so und ich
würde sagen es spricht alles dafür dass
wir diesen zweiten weg gehen dass also
um die qualifizierung dessen geht was
jetzt dran ist im lichte einer zukunft
und nicht dass wir sozusagen dieser
wetterbericht logik in der theologie
haben die irgendwelche spekulationen
wohl oder schlecht begründet über die
zukunft abgibt die gehören einen anderen
zuständigkeitsbereich sie haben einen
philosophischen text geschrieben zur
frage kann hoffnung tugend sein ich
möchte die frage etwas umdrehen und sie
so formulieren kann hoffnungslosigkeit
sünde sein
das ist ein wichtiger einwand gegen die
möglichkeit wiederum die statusfrage
sich vorzustellen und die frage dann so
zu beantworten das neben allem was die
hoffnung sonst auch noch sein kann eine
emotion eine disposition ein vermögen
oder einfach eine haltung eine
einstellung eben dass sie eine tugend
ist das ist natürlich in gewisser seien
zunächst aber moral liste oder
moralischer zuschnitt und dann fragt
sich ob die hoffnungslosigkeit und
resignation dann das laster sind als
gegenbegriff oder eine rundfunk und ja
nachdem nach aristoteles gibt es eben
die vorstellung dass eine tugend immer
zwei laster hat also die tugend des
mutes ist konfrontiert mit der mit dem
übermut und mit der
der tollkühnheit er wie er sagt und mit
der feigheit also sind sie sein spektrum
und in der mitte wäre man die tugend und
die wäre sozusagen hätte zwei laster
jetzt können wir uns fragen ob das auch
auf die hoffnung zutrifft also ob sie
dann gleich zwei laster hat dass wir
jetzt hier in ihren ihren einwand sogar
noch verstärken ja nicht nur eine
untugend sondern gleich zwei laster das
ist das ist ein einwand worum es mir
zunächst einmal ging mit der frage in
welcher weise wir hoffnung als tugend
verstehen können hängt mit der frage wie
man tugenden versteht und da gibt es die
vorstellung das tun denn wie igel sind
werkzeuge sind um einen wert zu
realisieren also wenn sie zum beispiel
den wert der wahrheit oder den wert der
wahrhaftigkeit nehmen
dann wäre die tugend auf diesen wert
ausgerichtet und wäre dass die
möglichkeit diesen wert zu realisieren
auf den wer das ausgerichtet und die
hoffnung könnte man genauso verstehen
das ist es einen bestimmten wert
realisiert den wir auch kultivieren
können
das kommt ja als weiteres element mit
der hoffnung hin mit der hoffnung als
tugend hinzu was wir tun denn wie ein
muskel trainieren können das heißt wir
unterlassen dieses training und damit
eben also wir können jetzt erlangen
india und erlangen ja da gibt es
verschiedene vorstellungen was jetzt
erlangen heißt die tierische tradition
hat mich immer gesagt dass die
biologisch relevanten tugenden glaube
hoffnung liebe wie es bei paulus heißt
dem apostel keine tugenden in dem sinne
sind dass wir sie uns selber geben
können sondern sie kommt von gott und
sind im strengen sinn eine gabe in der
philosophische tradition geht es eher
darum dass man tun denn ausbilden kann
möglicherweise gibt es eine disposition
dazu und dann kann man diese disposition
realisieren die dann aktiviert wird
durch bestimmte umstände
das kann man sogar sagen aber man kann
tugenden auch trainieren oder man kann
sie so ausbilden dass es eine
bildungsgeschichte gibt in welchen
kontexten sowohl geografisch einzeln als
auch kollektiv politisch tugenden
eigentlich ihren ort haben
da kommen wir wieder auf die hoffnung
wie muss eine gesellschaft beschaffen
sein im kollektiven oder auch wie muss
mein leben geschaffen in biografischen
in familiären im individuellen dass ich
eigentlich hoffen kann
da wird es dann sehr politisch da sehen
wir aber was mit der tugend der hoffnung
verbunden ist der einwand aber den sie
gebracht haben bleibt ja das ist
sozusagen folgerung gibt die durchaus
problematisch sind die sehe ich auch in
mir ging es eher um diese jetzt ich
hatte jetzt zwei elemente genannt die
wir gewinnen im verständnis der hoffnung
als tugend wenn wir das in diesem
moralischen kontext verhandeln
vielleicht ein punkt noch dazu zudem
dieser zuspitzung auf moral die mit den
fugen begriff zu verbunden zu sein
scheint das muss gerade zu sein wir
haben auch tugenden in einem
intellektuellen sind es gibt also auch
intellektuelle tun denn die nicht was
mit dem handeln und der moral zu tun
haben sondern die was mit dem erkennen
zu tun haben also etwas wie
umsichtigkeit klugheit vorsicht eine
gewisse ein gewisses wohlwollen in der
interpretation des anderen das sind
alles tun um die moral nichts zu tun
haben und man kann jetzt durchaus das
wäre dann das dritte element jetzt
hoffnung als tugend überlegen ob die
tugend der hoffnung außerhalb der moral
auch was mit dem erkennen zu tun hat
also dass derjenige der hofft und offen
durchs leben geht wie vorher angedeutet
leben das wäre das die welt oder das
eigene leben und erleben anders
wahrnimmt und dann haben wir etwas
erkenntnistheoretische so etwas ist so
logisch ist was mit dem begriff
verbunden ist das erst mal außerhalb der
moral steht
wir haben noch ein paar wenige minuten
und ich möchte gerne noch zwei aussagen
die sie auch im vorgespräch gemacht
haben
ein kurzer diskussion bringen nämlich
die eine ist sie sagen hoffnung ist mal
per sehen nicht als individuum geknüpft
es gibt zu einen kollektiven aspekt der
hoffnung ja was ist der kollektive
aspekt das subjekt der hoffnung kann
natürlich an den wiederum sein ich hoffe
dass das der fall ist ist ohne frage
so aber doch auch viel schneller von
einem hoffnungslosen menschen als von
einer großen gesellschaft ja wir können
aber natürlich ist durchaus uns die
frage vorlegen ob es nicht auch
gesellschaften die die hoffnung savannah
oder hoffnung safina sind wir können es
durchaus die frage vorlegen in welchen
zustand wir uns gerade befinden
es gibt also die möglichkeit das
hoffnungs objekt kollektiv zu verstehen
und damit kommen wir jetzt zu den
politischen hoffnungen und auch wiederum
zu den religiösen was wir im kollektiv
haben sei es in kleineren gruppen oder
auch in größeren es ist sozusagen ja
noch gar nicht gesagt was das kollektiv
dann ist aber jedenfalls mehr als einer
ist es ja so dass wir als gemeinschaft
oder als gemeinwesen uns auf einen
hoffnungslos richten und das ich dieser
art von gemeinschaft die sich sozusagen
auf dieses autos gut ein entwirft und
dieses auch ausgehandelt hat und wie
haben wir verschiedene möglichkeiten
politisch das zu tun dass damit
möglicherweise auch erst die
gemeinschaft entsteht also das bild wäre
nicht erst ist die gemeinschaft da und
dann eigentlich sie sich auf hoffnungs
güter sondern durch den prozess dass wir
uns auf hoffnungs güter verständigen
entsteht die gemeinschaft und was kommt
jetzt mit der hoffnung dann zusätzlich
ins spiel naja die erst der erste punkt
ist und das ist sozusagen die politische
dimension ist ich hoffe nicht allein
sondern ich habe mit hoffen und das mag
uns verbinden
es hat also etwas nicht nur
kollektivistische sondern etwas
kollektives im religiösen also in
religiösen gemeinschaften noch daher
kommt ja sozusagen die mehrzahl freunde
plural
es ist ja so dass ich nicht nur mit den
anrufen sondern für die anderen hoffe
also in der christlichen und religiösen
hoffnung ist es nicht so dass ein
hoffnung in die dual is muss oder
egoismus gibt dass wir auch wiederum ein
missverständnis zu glauben sondern ich
hoffe für alle anderen und mit allen
anderen die auch offen im glauben und da
sehen wir das so zu sagen da die
gemeinschaft entsteht mit blick auf ein
gut dass wir uns geben und das wir
aus handel also etwa auch in form von
gebeten oder fürbitte für andere
ich komme zum letzten punkt und ich
bitte wirklich hier um eine kurze
antwort obwohl ich weiß es ist
eigentlich noch mal ein großes fest dass
wir auf machen müssten sie sagten mir
auch wir leben in einer politisch
hoffnungslosen zeit ja damit ist
natürlich nicht gemeint das
hoffnungslose im politischen vollkommen
sind sagen ich habe da mal damit gemeint
dass wir in einer hoffnungslosen zeit
mit blick auf das politische leben was
ich erlebe ist dass wir eine einen
politischen kram atheismus haben der
zunächst einmal darauf abzielt dass wir
das politische als exekutive als
ausführendes organ als bürokratie als
verwaltung erleben dem vorgeschaltet ist
aber das erste was wir politisch machen
sollten nämlich die normativen fragen
stellen worauf wollen wir uns als
gemeinschaft eigentlich ausrichten was
ist das hoffnungs gut worauf wir uns
eigentlich freuen was macht uns
resilient gegenüber den hoffnungen die
möglicherweise aber auch auf
schwierigkeiten stoßen wie halten wir
das durch und was ist die relation zum
einen mit hoffenden mit denen ich
zusammen hoffe mein eindruck ist dass
die gegenwärtige politik das politische
leben reduziert auf die verwaltung und
die die durchführung und dem bürokratie
und diese normative dimension
unterschlägt und dafür leider keinen ort
weiß oder den zuordnen kann der hoffnung
und das vermisse ich dass wir sicher
noch mal stoff für eine nächste sendung
wir sind schon am ende und ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen dass sie
bei uns war dankeschön
unter dem titel mutig in die zukunft
beschäftigt sich srf kultur eine ganze
woche lang mit geschichten vom gelingen
zum beispiel gibt es morgen ab 9 uhr in
der sendung kontext auf radio sf1 ein
gespräch mit dem wirtschaftshistoriker
tobias straumann und dem schriftsteller
jonas löcher hier geht es jetzt weiter
mit der sternstunde philosophie
zu gast ist der deutsche schauspieler
lars eidinger in beispielloser offenheit
spricht er über das theater als sucht
die angst vor dem tod als urgrund seiner
kunst und das rauschhafte glück immer
wieder ein anderer zu werden
ihnen wünsche ich einen schönen sonntag
und bleiben sie hoffnungsvoll
[Musik]